live from the lobby of the headquarters
of Ramsey solutions Rebecca and her son
Chad are with us hey guys how are you
better than we deserve welcome so you're
here to do your debt-free scream yes sir
awesome so how much have you paid off
Rebecca one hundred one thousand five
hundred forty three dollars and 18 cents
I love it and how long did that take you
it took two years and 10 months Wow okay
making what kind of money during that
time we were making 78 and up to 132 up
to a hundred and thirty-two very good
okay so tell me the story of you getting
out of debt well my husband and I had a
law firm he was an attorney and we had
business debt we kept selling me out of
our lives we had a card debt
we had medical we had some back taxes
and we paid those all off at last August
he said let's go to a nearby park near
our home and let's do some planning and
he kept our snowball on a spreadsheet
for us and he said guess what we're
gonna be debt-free in January and we'd
worked so hard in this ex-wife chair we
paid her so I was really excited and we
did that planning in 11 days later he
died of a heart attack
oh my gosh and he said that date that
Sunday he said when we pay that last
debt I want to go to Nashville and meet
mr. rounds the empty and every scream my
so I'm here finishing that plan for us
and when he died after I could breathe
again I just made a decision to continue
with the plan and I did use a little bit
of my life insurance money thanks to you
he had it and um paid off one thing with
that bet old was she
he was only 67 oh my gosh and no no
signs of that the way you tell the story
is it's like it was a surprise like he
didn't know he had heart trouble it was
a real big surprise - minutes gone oh
yes so um I'm here finishing that plan
and I wanted to say my son introduced us
to you well only in German
cereals and said mom you really should
look into this because we were
struggling with our finances so I really
want to get to you got you got your dad
and mom started on this in chat yeah
something like that
but I've always struggled with money so
I I ran across your tools and your books
near all of your products and I learned
a lot from them so I was like hey mom
check this out paid off he's a broker
now and he uses that for his business oh
wow good for you good for you very cool
whoa that one takes my breath away you
you've been through a lot in the last 12
months yes but I want you to know I
bought a little house and paid cash did
you really that's good no mortgages for
me I like it you've done you are 100%
debt-free yes yeah
due to the do the due to having a plan
and having a system and I guess having a
having all your decisions about debt
made even in bad times yes and if I can
just say to other widows out there once
you can breathe again
make some good decisions get some health
and support so that you make good
decisions because we can't run from our
emotions so much yeah
it does take a little while to breathe
it really does and it gets better over
time but it never completely gets there
but thank goodness gracious and the good
news is you had a plan and had life
insurance and bad news is you've been
through this horrible process I'm so
sorry Wow
what a deal though and you know the good
news is - we know he's sitting in heaven
smiling I mean right he's loving this
that free call that you came all the way
over here to honor him with this and
honor what his game plan was that's just
very cool yeah that is very cool I'm
amazed this is neat and humbled ah very
cool good for you to be free I don't
know what else to say I'm just huh you
don't usually catch Dave Ramsey
speechless but yeah that just that does
that I'm gonna try to go to law school
because he always wanted me to Oh cuz
I'm gonna try to take the LSAT and see
if I can do it alright well I'll bet you
can yeah
same reason why you couldn't don't make
a great lawyer Wow
very neat I love it all right Rebecca
and Sun chatter what was your husband's
name Terry and Terry there we go a
hundred and two thousand dollars paid
off in two years and ten months making
seventy eight to one hundred and thirty
two and she's finishing the journey they
started together by being here to do the
debt free scream count it down
let's hear a debt free scream Wow oh my
goodness and that's why we come down
here every day
because this is work that matters thank
you lord